and finally new rules someone needs to
explain to me
why is bombing the only thing america
can do with precision
[Applause]
we can send a laser-guided missile down
an isis tunnel from a drone at 25 000
feet we can put one through a window
without even rustling the curtains
when it comes to killing machines we're
an atomic clock
for everything else we're a sundial in
the fog
after 9 11 we could have done what
israel would have done hunted down the
people actually involved and reinforce
the cockpit doors on planes precision
done who wants ice cream
but now we spent trillions attacking the
wrong country and creating a giant
homeland security bureaucracy we've now
spent decades in airport lines taking
off our shoes while tsa agents pat down
babies and grandmas
they say if you see something say
something
i see us afraid to identify threats by
likelihood
and bleeding ourselves dry just like bin
laden wanted us to
when people ask me why are you so
skeptical of what the medical
establishment tells us i say because
i've seen them react to a virus before
by 1987 cdc officials pretty much knew
how hiv was spreading and who was in
danger
now of course there's no moral dimension
to this despite what pat robertson used
to say
gay sex is just as loving natural and
cellulatory as the other kind but
science can be arbitrary and instead of
being precise and focusing on who should
be protected
we launched a fear campaign about how
aids was going to explode into the
heterosexual community oprah winfrey
summed up what people were hearing when
she said
research studies now project one in five
heterosexuals could be dead from aids by
but that didn't happen
and the upshot of bad information was
that in the late 1980s low-risk
americans were swamping testing
facilities and diverting our attention
and energy away from the truly at risk
new york in 2020 learned the hard way
how much better precision would have
been in prioritizing protecting the
nursing homes
contrary to popular lore covet is not
russian roulette
of course any virus anything
can kill anyone at any time
but we know who coveted kills
75 of cove deaths are people 65 and
older
98 to 99
are unvaccinated
who've died or been hospitalized were
overweight if you're obese and
unvaccinated or 85 and still crowd
surfing at music festivals
yes this will likely go badly for you
but at some point
but at some point that has to stop being
my responsibility doesn't it make more
sense to focus on helping the vulnerable
stay safe and let the rest of us go back
to living normal lives
[Applause]
there's always going to be another
variant we can't go on forever in
permanent hair on fire cancel christmas
hand jobs through a hazmat suit
freak the out mode i haven't been
to my office in two years that ficus
needs water
[Applause]
president biden's handling of the
pandemic started off polling pretty well
but now a majority disapprove
it's time to do what a growing list of
countries have done and announced we're
going back to something more like normal
beginning with recognizing that what
we're doing to kids is unnecessary and
horrible and i don't even like kids
but making kids who have a coveted
survivability rate of 99.98
mask up like bandits
unfortunately the thing that's getting
stolen is their education their sanity
and their social skills
a study this week from a professor at
johns hopkins concluded that the
lockdowns we all suffered through
had little impact in reducing covet
deaths
okay that's kind of a big one to get
wrong
last july president biden said you're
not going to get coveted if you have
these vaccinations well
i already knew that was wrong then and
now we all do
the former director of the cdc robert
redfield believes covet originated in a
lab and
now our intelligence agencies agree it
might have but for months on social
media it was banned to even discuss it
look i'm not saying the medical
establishment isn't trying to figure
out or that they're corrupt
although there is some of that
but
[Applause]
but how about just wrong
wrong a lot wrong about hiv wrong about
lockdowns drawing about kids wrong about
how you couldn't get it if you were
vaccinated
remember washing our packages
and there's never been any research
showing that outdoor transmission is
likely or common yet l.a county says
we're still supposed to mask up for big
outdoor events like we'll be at the
super bowl
well
supposed to
it's all theater watching athletes mix
it up on the court and then mask on the
sideline
not being able to touch a menu but
watching them touch my food
[Laughter]
masterless at dinner while sitting but
not standing
and by the way if applebee's really
cared about our health they would make
us cover our mouths after the food
arrived
i i'm just asking how much wrong
do you get to be
while still holding the default setting
for people who represent the science
eat eggs then don't then do
take aspirin then don't then do
the food pyramid really
bread and milk every day okay you do you
[Applause]
15 years ago they were recommending
trans fats
now they're illegal
just like almost 100 prescription drugs
which were once called safe and
effective and then yanked off the market
because they were not it reminds me of
how the republicans are constantly doing
traitorous things like trying to steal
elections and inviting the russians into
the oval office and somehow are still
known as the party of patriotism
[Applause]
we've had this problem in medicine for a
long time the same people who in private
care
always say get a second opinion
want to allow only one
in the public debate
but plainly the medical industrial
complex has not earned the right to
claim monopoly status on information
about this virus or medicine in general
yes free speech has allowed people to
hear misinformation sometimes and a lot
of it was yours
you